Today, the leader of the
volunteer mercenary group
fighting in eastern Ukraine, Yevgeny
Prigozhin, said his group's
next assignment may be in Russia
defending its territory.
And in the latest
and ongoing public feud
with Russian military officials,
he asked Russian prosecutors
to investigate
whether senior defense officials
committed a crime.
Now, for weeks,
as you may know,
Prigozhin has increased his criticism
of Russian military leadership.
He routinely now
appears in these self-produced videos
where he dresses up
like one of his mercenary
fighters and verbally attacks
Russia's top generals.
The question is, what's his endgame?
CNN's Melissa
Bell takes a look at the man
behind the powerful mercenary group.
Sure.
Just do it.
For months
now, Evgeny
Prigozhin has been
leading the charge in Ukraine
and stealing the limelight
right away
in the
guise Dumbo,
the Russian military version.
The taunt typical
as he announced
the withdrawal of his Wagner
mercenaries last week
after claiming the first Russian advance
in Ukraine in months.
Power on the ground that has translated
into far more open
political confrontation with Moscow.
Long known by his nickname
as Putin's chef,
the oligarchs
shared the Russian president's
humble beginnings
in the tough
neighborhoods of Saint Petersburg.
Reportedly a former convict.
He used Putin's rise
to build a vast catering empire.
As Putin set his sights on Crimea
and eastern Ukraine in 2014,
Prigozhin forces were there.
The vulgar mercenary group
that he founded became known
as Putin's private army,
operating on his behalf.
But in the shadows
across the Middle East
and Africa for years, Wagner did it.
But it took the chaos of the 2022 Russia
invasion of Ukraine
for Prigozhin
to take center stage himself.
Shakoor Gerasimov
flexing his power
and his voice, villagers who are,
which he raised loudly again
this week against Russia's
top military brass
after drone attacks on Moscow
brought the war
far too close to home for comfort.
We realize this means
some are borrowing
that you are the Ministry of Defense.
You didn't do a damn thing
to stamp this out.
Why are you allowing these drones
to fly to Moscow?
Because propaganda is arguably
what Evgeny Prigozhin does best
setting up
this notorious troll
farm in St Petersburg,
which was blamed
for pumping out disinformation
around the 2016 U.S.
presidential election.
Prigozhin was sanctioned by the U.S.
despite denying any involvement.
You, your community together.
Now he is personally
taking his propaganda machine on the road
and across Russia,
turning his attention to what he calls
the enemy at home
with increasingly obvious
political ambitions of his own.
While the system was stable,
there was no place for him.
And he was waiting and waiting.
And then the system started collapsing.
And he found that openly.
And he burst into the system.
Interested Virginia
and Russia's political system,
just like its
history,
appears to be
something Prigozhin is very aware of.
Soldatov stuffed up neatly.
All these divisions
can end up in a revolution,
just like in 1917.
First, the soldiers will stand up
and after death
their loved ones will rise up.
If I editable them
with precautions, very thinly
veiled threats.
He's also now clearly
hoping that Russian society
may be ready for a message
even more hardline
than that of the man who helped make him.
And that, Anderson, is very much
the point.
There have been so many questions
these last few months
about why
there has been no rebuke
from Vladimir
Putin,
even in the face
of such outspoken criticism
on the part of Evgeny Prigozhin.
The key to that
is that Prigozhin is himself
a far more hard line
even than Vladimir Putin.
If it were up to him,
there would be mass mobilizations,
any semblance of democracy and a veneer
would be swept aside
in the name of
winning the war in Ukraine.
That is Vladimir Putin's problem.
He cannot be cracking down
both on the election. Navalny's.
The more moderate
reformist parts of Russian society
and taking on the ultranationalists
like canny prigozhin.
So in a sense he is face now with the man
on whom he's come to depend in Ukraine,
making it more and more clear
that it is perhaps also Vladimir Putin
That now
depends on Evgeny Prigozhin inside
Russia itself.
Andrew Fascinating.
Isabelle, Thank you so much.